- I got the real clown
here, the queen clown!
(laughs)
- [Bella] That's right.
(upbeat music)
- Hi, everyone!
I'm Bella DeLune and I am a
professional makeup artist.
What made me create the clown contouring
was a collaboration that I did
with another makeup artist.
Basically, came out with
the idea to respond to
a lot of the hate that we
were getting on social media.
I, personally, was called
a clown all the time.
I said well, I'ma show you
what a real clown looks like.
I'm able to express myself through makeup.
Today, I'm gonna be showing you
the clown contouring on someone else
and I'm also going to be doing highlight
and contour on different skin tones
and we're gonna have fun with it!
- My relationship with
makeup does not exist.
- Makeup terrifies me.
- I love makeup.
I just suck at it so badly. (laughs)
- I've walked into a couple makeup stores,
I remember in high school,
and that just scared me.
- I have a vision when I put on makeup
and I want that vision
to actually be realized
and actually look like
how I see it in my head.
- I think I'm excited to do something
totally different than I usually do.
- This'll be the first time that anyone
will see me with makeup on.
- Turn me into Kim Kardashian! (laughs)
(upbeat techno music)
♫ Make the whole party stand up ♫
- I'm feeling a little Ruby Rose vibe.
So we're gonna go ahead and do that.
- I'm glad I can't see the process,
just because, like, when you watch, like,
YouTube videos or
whatever, they look crazy.
- The BuzzFeed clown contour.
Face forward, but eyes up.
- Oh.
- Yeah, face forward.
- Face forward.
- [Bella] Eyes up, yeah.
- [Client] Eyes up.
- See how it's light,
medium, and then dark
so when you blend that, it's
actually gonna be much easier.
The reason why we put all these
different colors on her
face, some are gonna act
as blush, some is gonna
act like a color corrector,
some, obviously, is gonna
highlight and contour the face.
So I'm putting a lightweight foundation.
What I'm doing is I'm
just color matching you
and then I'll go in there
with a little bit of highlight
and then I'll go in with a
little bit of contour as well.
I can't wait to blend everything together!
(upbeat techno music)
♫ Dedication
♫ Yeah, yeah
♫ Yeah
♫ Yeah, yeah, yeah
♫ Yeah, yeah
♫ Yeah
♫ Yeah, yeah, yeah
♫ Give us all, give us
all, give us all bass
♫ Give us all, give us all, give us all
♫ Dedication ♫
- I have no idea what I look like!
- My face actually feels less oily.
- I'm really excited to look. (laughs)
- Oh, my god! (laughs)
I look really bad ass!
I'm like afraid to look again. (laughs)
- Hot damn! (laughs)
- I would never know that I
looked like a clown before this.
I feel like I'm a painting.
- My best Ruby Rose look?
Oh, I can give you like
a little eyebrow thing.
- I like that it's made
makeup not as intimidating.
It kind of has to happen in steps.
- Even if, like, I love the
way I look without makeup,
by putting on certain types of makeup
or certain colors, like,
it enhances my personality
that I wanna show through.
- I probably won't do this on my own.
It was just nice to learn a little bit
about, like, even basic makeup.
- This is art though, I appreciate this.
("How Close")
(whoosh)
(hinge squeaks)